when Mexico sends its people they're not
sending their best they're not sending
you they're not sending you they're
sending people that have lots of
problems and they're bringing those
problems with us when Donald Trump
claimed in 2015 that Mexican immigrants
will ravage our women destroy our
neighborhoods and taint our ethnic and
cultural purity he entered into a
long-standing well cultivated American
tradition of xenophobia and
fear-mongering
in the late 19th century poet Emma
Lazarus celebrated the huddled masses
yearning to breathe free and the
wretched refuse who came to America for
a better life but Prescott Hall the
co-founder of the powerful immigration
restriction League offered a rebuttal
first enough enough we want no more of
ye immigrant from a foreign Shore
already is our land overrun with toiler
beggar thief and scum after a century of
mostly open borders in which tens of
millions of European immigrants became
Americans members of the wasp
establishment decided in the 1920s that
the United States could no longer accept
what they denounced as beaten men from
beaten races in terms that will sound
familiar today Jews Italians and others
they claimed were incapable of
assimilating into a country based on
private property limited government and
hard work in 1924 the restriction asjuan
a massive and long-lasting legislative
battle with passage of the Johnson Reid
Act which completely prohibited
immigration from Asia and sharply
limited immigration from Europe based on
the country of origin under the new law
for instance just four thousand Italians
were allowed to enter the country each
year down from an average well above
200,000 in each year of the preceding
decade national origins would remain the
basis of u.s. immigration law until 1965
the guarded gate bigotry eugenics and
the law that kept two generations of
Jews Italians and other European
immigrants out of America a new book by
Daniel Okrent looks at the ways in which
xenophobia and pseudoscience combined to
fundamentally alter immigration policy
at the start of what became known as the
American century Okrent was the first
public editor of the New York Times and
is the author of last call a history of
prohibition
he sat down with reason to talk about
how old debates over immigration and
America's national character
our newly relevant to contemporary
politics Daniel Okrent thanks for
talking to reason it's my pleasure and
before we get started I do want to say
upfront if we don't make a lot of sense
it's because you're descended from
polish and Romanian Jews so we can't
expect that amazing it even let me into
your and I my mother's family's from
outside Naples and you quote people
talking about Neapolitans as a
degenerate class that were infected with
spiritual hookworm displaying a
distressing frequency of low foreheads
open mouths weak chins poor features and
backless heads so you know you've been
warned give me the elevator pitch of
your book beginning in the middle of the
1890s when the emigration from eastern
southern Europe was accelerating and
Ellis Island was over over with almost
overwhelmed people coming in and the
slums began to grow in the large city of
the Northeast a very very strong
anti-immigration movement began for 20
years some very well-connected people
both in Congress and out passed laws and
four times President's veto those laws
that would have limited immigration from
those countries to some degree then in
1915 1916 something was dropped in their
lap which was a book called the passing
of the great race by a really
interesting scary character named
Madison grant and that brought the two
things together he brought the eugenic
idea which had been developing since
Darwin really over the preceding 60
years and he connected that to the
anti-immigration feelings that these
races are genetically inferior and so
suddenly the anti-immigration people
they had science on their side they
weren't bigots and then in 1917 they
were able to pass the first kind of
major well they passed literacy of
seventeen the literacy test and it's a
vetoed and then they pass it over the
veto but by that time that had happened
this literacy test that was meant to
keep out the uneducated people of the
eastern and southern European countries
their education levels in those
countries had begun to increase so it
was enough to use illiteracy as the
excuse to keep them out they needed
another excuse
and the American scientific
establishment of coming from the
greatest institutions in the country
provided them with this excuse and was
junk science we'll get to that in a
second I mean it's a it's an incredible
sluggers row of do you know everybody in
America I mean it's Eleanor Roosevelt
it's you know that Teddy Roosevelt
obviously w eb des bois all of them were
anti-immigrant and or you genesis but
set the scene a little bit in the late
19th century who is coming to america
ended what numbers and why
well the immigration from Europe begins
to change around 1870 1880 it begins to
accelerate there are two key drivers of
this one is the desperate poverty in
southern Europe particularly southern
Italy in Greece and part of the the
Slavic countries and in the Northeast
nor the East part of Europe the
incredible anti-semitism that pogroms
against the Jews the the racial laws
that confined Jews living in certain
areas kept them out of certain
occupations limited the amount of
education they can so people from these
two areas really have an impetus they
have a reason to want to live to leave
and then they're handed the ways of the
means of doing it which is a
transcontinental railroad network you
know before the railroads quick
crisscross Europe for somebody who lived
in a shtetl in eastern Poland to get to
a port was a really difficult thing but
now it could be done who has already
been excluded from America well that's I
mean it's an interesting on the
backstory and absolutely it goes in the
cycle in this country and it's we are
the land of the free keep out we are the
land of the free keep out it goes back
to the 1750s when Benjamin Franklin
wanted to keep Germans out of
Pennsylvania then we're more open to it
then the Irish come and there's a very
strong anti Irish feeling that was
efforts to keep them out that failed and
the Irish population grew very rapidly
of course 1882 is probably the most
horrible anti immigration law in US
history the China the the Chinese
restriction act which absolutely limited
and the further immigration of any chai
Chinese into the country so they've been
these cycles and there been other groups
that have been kept out you know
suddenly was these new ones
what were the immigration restrictions
particularly afraid of because I mean
they they talking great at great length
but what was their primal fear I think
that it's this basic is that any group
of people needs another group of people
to hate to look down on but then it gets
aggravated by the presence and their
lives of people that they never expected
to find in their lives so in Boston for
instance where the immigration
restriction movement really took hold
and it was sort of a the you know the
heart of the restriction movement in
Back Bay people are living on in
beautiful houses on Commonwealth Avenue
in less than a mile away where the
horrible slums of the South End and the
West End North End so these people are
impinging on us and what are they going
to do not only to our city in our
country but to our families there's this
terrible fear that has manifested
manifest the fear manifests itself
primarily in Teddy Roosevelt's
presidency of intermarriage between the
so called anglo-saxon peoples and those
from these other and the anglo-saxons
eventually became Nordic yeah this was
this was a point in late 1890s that
divided Europe into three racial groups
in fact the first such division was
stated by William Z Ripley of MIT and he
said was Teutonic which were the German
people who also spread into Scandinavian
to the UK Alpine and Mediterranean it
was only when the Germans suddenly
became our enemies in World War one did
it change from German to Nordic and that
was the phrase and the Alpine's then are
kind of the French yeah I mean it's
obviously these are bad categories it's
most yeah I you know the French
primarily the French Belgians you could
probably you know you know the Austrians
were they were cool maybe the Moravians
I don't know it was a messy thing but
they adjusted these categories to suit
their particular political needs at any
given time so the immigration
restriction us have their fear and a lot
of it it's about miscegenation or
race-mixing and things like that what
about the you Genesis the Genesis begin
with a very different program it starts
in England really comes right out of the
Darwinian revolution 1859 Darwin
publishes origin of the species and
suddenly the accepted view of the
origins of mankind is thrown out the
view that today we'd call creationism
once you realize
that we're not all descended from Adam
and Eve then we are not all brothers we
are not already related then you can
have distinctions between people and you
can look down on them as being
genetically different it's in fact a
cousin of Darwin's Francis the golf a
really interesting strange character or
gentleman gentleman scientists who coins
the word eugenics and puts forth the
idea that the UK can be improved if we
can get the best to marry the best his
big idea was to have picked the 5000
best young men the 5,000 best young
women have them all married in one
ceremony arranged marriages presided
over by Queen Victoria in Westminster
Abbey and then pay them several thousand
pounds a year so they could not have to
work they could just create babies well
that's good work if you can get it yet
that it changes and he well he also
coined the term nature and / nature
versus nurture later and yeah he takes
that out of Shakespeare and also the
base of the basic in Garmon arguments
have gone on forever is that environment
or is it genes that that's really and
he's very much then it's mostly genes
yeah entirely genes although they're
selecting the the best people he notices
that that not only do they come from the
same families they come from
well-established families that have sent
their kids to college and and had
private tutors and all the other things
that the upper class has had but the in
that I give negative eugenics is the one
that that becomes talking about such as
positive eugenics is just the idea we
all kind of participate in some form of
you know positive eugenics you you pick
a mate that you like and you want to
have kids with what's the negative the
negative is to stop people you don't
like from having kids and you know
that's obviously a oversimplification
but the first movement the expression of
eugenics was was efforts to keep peple
epochs the so-called feeble-minded and
the blind that can generally blank and
can generally deaf from reproducing
because if we could weed those out of
the population we would have a better so
it's it's like I mean it's totally taken
from livestock and a big player and your
book is the American breeders
Association which is kind of like
livestock humans it's all the same a lot
of the the wealthy people who sponsored
the movement like Mary Harriman the
Averell Harriman's mother and the widow
of the railroad baron M she was she was
a [ __ ]
breeder can she released oh yeah well if
you do this and this now what they
didn't realize and what the the wiser
geneticists knew that it would take
250,000 generations to really get rid of
all of these things and they're also I
mean they're talking about breeding but
they don't really have the genetic
revolution hasn't happened yet
right the the but they do know what
they've been doing with their lives die
and they do know what they've been doing
with plants and peas and stuff like that
now the bees yeah Mendel's peas well you
know nobody paid attention to Mendel
nobody knew he was even alive until
thirty years after he was dead and then
around the turn of the century of the
Mendelian revolution ties to this
eugenic idea and suddenly it's the
hottest thing in science what about the
pseudoscience because this is you know
you you stress throughout the book that
scientists know what they know but then
that often gets overturned and we're not
talking about marginal figures here
really I mean in some ways we are but
mostly this is a kind of scientific
establishment in America or very smart
people at very big institutions whether
it's MIT or Stanford or in the Museum of
Natural History what are some of the big
instances where they just thought they
were doing science but it was just
totally kind of bunkum
primarily had to do with the kind of
investigation and testing that they did
of those whom they had determined were
genetically inferior so Charles
Davenport who was the leading scientist
and is a very very accomplished and
important animal geneticist
he then tiptoes into the world of humans
and he oh my god this is so exciting we
can applied the same principles to it
but let's go out and find out whether
these people are genetically good or not
so they conduct he gets college students
on summer vacation trains them for a
week or two and then sends them out to
poor neighborhood sense about two to
closed off parts of the world where
people have been inbreeding and they're
to determine the genetic value of the
human being who's there they're
interviewing without any acknowledgement
of what the environment has done to
these people so this was a base a
fundamental error that was clear even at
the time to the British eugenicist who
said this is junk don't pay attention to
it but it was so exciting for the
Americans who wanted to put it to use
can you talk about the intelligence test
particularly the early one
that are just egregious and what they
how they measured intelligence
well there's any number of ways that you
can look at it there's one series of
tests conducted by HH goddard on Ellis
Island where they would pick people and
put them through some basic kind of IQ
tests you know shapes and numbers and
things like this but they only pick the
people who looked like they might be a
problem you know that's all those people
you know he's okay he's okay he's
speaking you know pretty good his
sentences are fine well let's test this
guy well what do you get from them they
found out that 80% of the Jews were
genetically deficient in their
intelligence 65% of Hungarians 70% of
Bulgarians I mean it was lunacy and
Goddard himself he cut the numbers in
half just arbitrarily because he
couldn't believe them either and then
not too many years later he recanted
entirely but the lied that travels
around the world before the truth is
found was the case here too
virtually everybody in the book going
back to earlier days in American history
up through say the early thirties
everybody was either you know first up
everybody hated Jews and Italians and
and or embrace eugenics and I mean the
list of people and this is incomplete
but it's Samuel Morse that telegraph guy
Frederick Douglass WB Dubois Margaret
Sanger Calvin Coolidge Woodrow Wilson
Eleanor Roosevelt Charles Francis Adams
who was a great early d'Avray glader
Samuel Gompers the union leader James J
Hill the Empire Builder Sidney Webb HT
Wells Oliver Wendell Holmes I mean the
the list is virtually endless every page
has another great American figure or
British figure what was going on at this
you know that they were both
anti-immigrant and you Genesis well that
list is a mix of them right some were
just anti certain kinds of immigrants
but but it gets back to that notion of
not letting somebody into my club until
the mass migration across the ocean in
the 1880s 1890s it happened in the West
Coast earlier than that with the Chinese
but until the 1880s 1890s these people
weren't noticeable and suddenly there's
something that is strange that looks
different speaks differently smells
different and it's horrifying
you mentioned Eleanor Roosevelt and I
think it's worth explaining that one
she I usually use it as a punch line who
is the woman who would have said these
things and she said some pretty awful
anti-semitic things when she was 33
years old she commented on she'd rather
be hung
she said hung instead of hanging she'd
rather be hung rather than have to go to
another Jew party and hear all the talk
of money jewels and Sables and then I
say at the end of the paragraph and who
was that woman it was the paragon of
Tolerance Eleanor Roosevelt so the
normative sentence that's what you grow
up around that's that's natural to you
The Addams Family I mean it they were
deep into it I mean Henry Adams Charles
Francis brother was just phenomenal
anti-semite many were able to break free
of that many were not well you know your
book has many villains and I'm gonna
throw out some names and if you could
kind of give a quick summary or or why
these people are important you've talked
about Francis Galton's he's kind of a
he's kind of this the beginning of a
biological genetic determinism that goes
into you job what he wants to do is plan
reproduction so you can see we'll get
the Margaret Sanger later I'm sure
there's a real connection no matter what
you think of what Sanger did in terms of
birth control generally it both has to
do with planning and controlling
reproduction he was the one who first
had that notion and so I mean part of
this is there's the Industrial
Revolution you know things are becoming
more regimented sciences on the march so
there's that this belief that we can
control things in a very planned and
orderly way well there's also the
progressive movement which is a critical
element the progressives were not
lowercase Democrats they thought that
government government can be used to
improve the nation to broome improve
people's lives we're gonna do the
deciding and we're gonna use science to
do it so that was the perfect timing for
this notion of eugenics to be embraced
policy a Henry Cabot Lodge Henry Cabot
Lodge the first Henry Cabot Lodge the
first person who actually had the titled
majority leader of the US Senate he was
the legislative father of the movement
he's the one who gave the speech and
introduced the legislation in 1895 for
the literacy test and he made no bones
about it he listed the countries we
didn't want people from that story
changes later but he was also very good
on race issues right he was he was laid
out for blacks at a time when nobody
totally believed in
and getting voting rights through the
plat flats he saw what was happening in
reconstruction he really wanted to stop
that people are complicated it's also
important to realize that Henry Cabot
Lodge lived much closer to the Italians
and the Jews that he did to the southern
blacks yeah so you can kind of
romanticize me a little bit
Joely Joely is to me the most
interesting character in the book are
one of the most interesting characters
he was the first citizen of Boston a
very very wealthy man never had to work
and he was phenomenally philanthropic
and he supported everything from black
schools and black churches in Boston he
started the Massachusetts Civic League
which was a good government organization
funded entirely he kept he was chairman
of the Boston School Committee and he
kept the schools open at night so the
immigrants could learn to speak English
on the other hand Jolie was the single
benefactor he he financed for three
decades the immigration restriction
League which was the you know the key
political organization and he said in
his private correspondence things like
you know soon Europe will be drained of
all of its choose perhaps to its
advantage but not ours so were you able
to get inside his head like just how
does he maintain that kind of massive
contradiction well I believe that he
believed it's never articulated let's
keep these people out but once they're
here we had better civilize them and the
very term civilize them the verb with
the verb at the time was Americanized
but it meant civilized make them like us
make them be similar to us you mentioned
her already but Mary Harriman Mary
Herman inherited this enormous fortune
in 1907 1908 when her husband the
railroad baron eh Harriman died she did
not set up a foundation she dispensed
the money herself she was the richest
woman in America and one of the her
initial benefactions was for the
eugenics Record Office in Cold Spring
Harbor New York where the so-called
research well it was research it was
lousy research where the research began
and that's how the next person is
Charles Davenport
he was the Davenport was the the father
of eugenics in America
question and he had such credibility as
a scientist for the work he had done
with poultry primarily and other animals
that people believe him they thought
that this guy was the real thing so he
was a and he was passionate he was the
kind of man who if he had an idea and he
liked the idea that's all he'd talk
about for months to come in his case it
was years to come but it's important to
know about Davenport he began saying
let's keep out of the country and
immigration these deficient individuals
it wasn't races when he started right he
so he was a eugenicist but he was kind
of an individualist he didn't he didn't
at some point he said that there's no
race per se it's dangerous and none
undesirable exactly particular
individuals that's a problem that's 1911
in 1920 he says to Batterson grant can
we build a wall high enough to keep out
these inferior sounding so contemporary
so Madison grant you know if you've met
Madison grant you would probably like
him he was this debonair handsome and
very witty great manners started the
Bronx Zoo Save the Redwoods America's
leading conservationists and just a
monstrous anti-semite
you know Schuyler I've never encountered
in in the US before since and he really
devoted his life he had an enormous
fortune to draw on beginning around 1915
to the anti immigration cause and he
stayed with it through the rest of his
life and in his book this book was the
passing of the great race and if you
read it it's kind of charmingly written
it's very lively and it uses all this
language of different you know in in the
solar train era when the the Goths met
up with the something I've heard of
Goths and these other groups that you
had the ESTs wow he really knows his
stuff well it was all made up it was
really based almost on nothing you know
why would see taken seriously he was
trained as a lawyer but then he was kind
of passing himself off as he's chairman
of the board
he starts the bloody Bronx Zoo he's
chairman of the board of the American
Museum of Natural History the leading
Natural History institution in the
country of course he had that job
because the director was the equally
anti-semitic anti-italian Henry
Fairfield Osborn who was his very best
friend so he had that credential behind
him Osbourne wrote an introduction for
the book Osbourne was the man who
discovered Tyrannosaurus Roxy it was a
great great tele intelligence and a
great popularizer he had a national
reputation so people are paying
attention to him and Charles Scribner
meets him says yeah I'll publish this
book Charles Scribner my publisher that
Charles himself but I'm published by
scrim their hands the manuscript to a
young man in his office named Maxwell
Perkins whose name we know from else how
he was next on my list so talk a little
bit of Maxwell Perkins as the premiere
literary editor in America in a kind of
modern American literature he was the
editor Fitzgerald in Hemingway and many
many distinguished figures we know
they've made a movie about him he was
such a good editor to the creative
writers at no and there is something
called the Maxwell Perkins Center for
fiction was a very well endowed
philanthropy to support fiction writers
I had never I worked in publishing
business for ten years I had never heard
anybody say a bad word about Maxwell
Perkins he was also a nice man and he
had good sense of humor but he also
published me at Madison grant and he
added at Madison grants second edition
third edition fourth edition wrote
promotional letters to people who you
know it turned out to be proto Nazis and
some of them turned out to be Nazis he
published another guy named Arthur
Stoddard who in some ways was even worse
because he wrote he wrote bestsellers
and even was still publishing Madison
grant in 1933 that's a bad year and then
finally and Albert Johnson Albert
Johnson otherwise forgotten to history
was a newspaper editor for the Pacific
Northwest who really hated the Japanese
and the Chinese and when he ran for
Congress in 1912 that was his entire
platform now he pursued various other
interesting some valid some really awful
policies one the one thing that Johnson
pursued that I'm all in favor of he
wanted to move to the metric system but
that failed what worked was he was
chairman of the immigration committee
and the Johnson Reed act is in the
Johnson reading to talk a little bit
about that yeah that the 1924 act that's
kind of the comb
that's the climate of this well it's a
long sustained climax they act was
enforcement 41 years this is the law
that determined that there would be
quotas on individuals on people coming
from specific countries so if let us say
10% of all Americans came from Germany
those already living here that of the
immigrants allowed him this year 10%
would come from Germany and so on down
the line but Johnson and his colleagues
they said well you know if we do this
based on the composition in the American
population in 1920 we're gonna have a
awful lot of these people in it so let's
use an earlier census even though you
know they're passing this legislation
23:24 not the 1910 census not the 1900
census they go back to the 1890 census
before the real influx of Eastern
southern Europeans came in to reduce
those numbers as much as possible and
the the grass best illustration I think
is the Italian quota there had been as
many as 220,000 Italians coming in and
in a single year in the last two years
before this law and after the law was
enacted the quota was fewer than 4,000 a
year you talk about scenes of where I
tear up even think about a people coming
across the ocean and the quota has been
filled by the time they're there so it's
like because there's 300 people that are
allowed yeah particular country it was
and it was also measured by month they
were trying to regulate through the
month so you had this incredible scene
in New York Harbor where big ships
coming in they couldn't come in until it
was August first of the first of the
months they had to wait until midnight
and then race to Ellis Island see who
got there first because there weren't
enough slots left for people from both
ships and in one particular case one
Greek ship had to just turn around and
take everybody home to give a sense of
you know again reading this book these
people are fascinated because they're
you know so on the one hand you have
somebody like Madison Grant who is
saving every wood redwood he can find
and you know and and helping preserve
land in Alaska and in the West and
whatnot and then on the other hand it's
just like a vile race but there's
something consistent there no he wants
to preserve the American
scape and he wants to preserve the
American blood stream it was this his
particular idealized version of America
and in fact if you read some of his
writings about the environment you know
it's a tax on the big mining companies
and the timber could have been written
by a modern environmentalist this
connected integrally to his sense of who
America was what America was and who it
was well one of the things I was going
to say is I mean there's so many odd
contradictions it seems and you know
another character who shows up his every
day Ross who's a racist who coined the
term race suicide but he's also what's
his academic background and what what is
his legacy and contemporary academia you
know he's a sociologist starts at
Stanford he gets fired at Stanford for
saying something that the Stanford
family didn't like about hiring Chinese
coolies Stanford was a railroad King he
got fired from that job and that creates
a great controversy which leads to the
fact of the founding of the American
Association of University Professors and
the idea of tenure that you can't get
fired for say something something you
know college professors now can thank an
absolute racist or you know the job
protections they have well he was a
racist for a long time but like so many
of these people it's an interesting
recantation and we may be getting a
little bit ahead of the story but Ross
who was called himself a socialist
Robert LaFollette was his one of his
very closest friends and allies he
became the head of the the National
chairman of the ACLU later in life but
early on his comments you know referring
to the immigrants they look like people
from the ice age who living in waddled
huts and they don't really the worst
most racist comments about you know
Romanians Bulgarians whomever it might
make he actually said about the Slavs
Slavs will endure conditions that no
white man will endure and I say is he
the one who said that it's something
like asan or Riley can outwork azam azam
didn't under live Riley yeah yeah and
then meaning one more horrible thing
after another and then in 1936 like many
of the others he says oh my god look
what I've done that everything I have
said has only encouraged what we're
seeing across the ocean in Germany and
he says i rue this published a an
apology a little late but it was
literally a genuine apology well let's
talk about some of the heroes there
aren't a lot of heroes in the book but
there's some and Grover Cleveland yeah
Grover Cleveland in the last 24 hours of
his second and final term as president
vetoes the literacy test that had just
passed and he very clearly says this
isn't America you know we are founded on
being an open door and we this is pure
discrimination in kind of a noble moment
for him and that four years after grant
particular saying well we all know that
what he really objected to was this
other one paragraph in the measure that
had something to do with Canadian
tariffs well no that's what grant wanted
it to be
what about Franz boas Franz boas was the
great German born anthropologist really
the the greatest figure in the history
of American anthropology taught at
Columbia where to the Museum of Natural
History and he knew from the beginning
that this was bogus and he camp
campaigned very very hard against it but
he just wasn't listened to he when
grants book is published he writes a
savage review in The New Republic and
the way the grant dealt with it was very
simple of course he's Jewish they do
this sort of thing Emanuel Celler
Manny seller who was a congressman in
Brooklyn when I first moved to New York
50 years ago he was a freshman
congressman from Brooklyn American born
Jewish parents went to Columbia Law
School and in 1924 in the house
immigration Committee he was the only
member who voted against the Johnson
Reed act and then 41 years later he is
still in in the house he's chairman of
the Judiciary Committee and the bill
that revokes Johnson Reid is named after
him right and he lasted up until what
the very early 70s yes Elizabeth
Holtzman beat him yeah weird Congress so
by the mid 20s the restriction is the
immigration research nurse of totally
won they passed the laws that said
quotas and they'd you were talking about
based on the 1890 census the use Genesis
had also won in a big way what
some what were their victories like well
they first of all in the academic world
it became part of the curriculum and the
number of universities that taught in it
as as received science in name of the
University and and it was done that way
the other much more insidious one was
sterilization the genesis at the same
time they were working against
immigration they were working to promote
the idea of sterilizing the unfit and
they particularly aimed it at people
because for obvious reasons who were
living under so-called state control
they were in prisons they were in alms
houses they were in institutions for
them for the mentally ill so the state
was their guardian and the their
campaign was well let's sterilize all
these people so we don't have any more
insane or any more criminals or so on
involuntarily and this this became part
of policy in something you know from 39
40 states 1927 there's a famous Supreme
Court decision where Oliver Wendell
Holmes the great liberal progressive
roll you know believer in freedom and
liberty
he believes the government has the right
to do this he compares it to vaccination
he says that oh yeah that sterilization
we look we vaccinate people why can't we
do that and he says in his decision
three generations of imbeciles is enough
and more than 70,000 Americans were
sterilized under that doctrine they were
sterilized in California as late as the
1970s you alluded to this before what
what broke the spell of the the twin
kind of policies of immigration
restriction and new Genesis well the
spell of eugenics was the one that broke
immigration restrictions stuck around
for various reasons but it was Hitler
and in fact a lot of the American New
Genesis had been in regular touch and
and cooperation with the German New
Genesis now the German eugenicist in
1922 when Davenport was dealing with
them were not arguing racial genex at
that point but when Hitler comes in they
definitely definitely do and Hitler says
to the genesis of the conference and now
without you everything I do will not
work I need you
my program is dependent on the doctors
and the the euthanasia program the
planned marriage program Ella and then
everything leading up to the the
Holocaust
kind of comes out of this idea of a
racialized eugenics now most American
eugenicist s-- ran away from it
most scientific institutions like the
Carnegie Institution the Rockefeller
Foundation the Museum of Natural History
they said oh my what have we done we
have to get away from it surprising
number of individuals stayed with it and
the key one is Harry Laughlin who was
the leader of the sterilization campaign
who in 1936 about less than two months
after the Faculty of the University of
Heidelberg was purged of its Jews 25
percent of the faculty he is granted an
honorary degree for being the Farsi
Farsi avail policy in America
Hitler acknowledges Madison grant
several times in speeches there was a
real connection so unless you were
Madison grant or Harry Laughlin you
wanted to have nothing to do with it
what prompted you to write this book now
well I've never been so happy to be a
year and a half late on a book because I
wasn't anticipating that it would become
the issue that has to become my last
book as you know we talked about it
several years ago as a history of
prohibition and prohibition without
going into that book was used as an anti
immigrant political tool for a variety
of reasons by Methodist Baptist
ministers and largely in the in the
Midwest and the south so this notion of
political warfare against people from
elsewhere is what promote it prompted me
to look into it a little bit more the
prohibition book you know also made an
argument that prohibition ones are kind
of dry you know this is a bad pun dry
run firms more on drugs but it led to
something else that is still with us
with immigration it's you know what is
still with us and because the eugenics
is not there but there's clearly a
please and you gents not there but but
the the identification of unwanted
racial groups is there Muslim
Central Americans you know it's not Jose
and maybe who I am but not Roberto it's
not and it's not picking individuals who
are bad for America but picking nations
who are bad for America in this
particular doctrine so there's no
eugenic sense behind it there's no
eugenic pretensions behind it it's
something very very different it's
directly discriminatory what do you hope
people will take away from your book the
dangerous thing is to think of how bad
guys can take things from the books I
don't want to go to those if this is
going to sound like a third-grade civics
class but judge the person by who the
person is and not where the person comes
from or who his or her parents were or
even you know the community that he or
she leads him and that is so fundamental
as I say it's a third grade civics class
it's embarrassing to say it but it is at
the very core of not only what this
nation is but what I'm writing about in
the book because that was not done for
over 40 years well thank you we're gonna
leave it there we've been talking with
Daniel Okrent his book most recently is
the guarded gate bigotry eugenics and
the law that kept two generations of
Jews Italians and other European
immigrants out of America dan thank you
pleasure
you
[Music]